aujourd'hui au palais de justice de
vesoul à la barre du tribunal nous
retrouvons le jeune père de famille qui
est poursuivi pour violences conjugales
et outrage à agent on vous reproche
d'avoir menacé de mort madame ce de
façon réitérée en l'espèce et notamment
du déclarant à plusieurs reprises je
vais te tuer et en ville en un coup de
poing sur son visage
quelques heures plus tôt dans le bureau
du procureur
et même la première fois j'ai jamais
tapé ma compagne au moment de leur
interpellation quand les possibles ici
son arrivée s'est mal passé franchement
ce programme eux ont déposé plainte
contre vous en disant que vous les aviez
insulté fils de pub espèce de sous merde
ce que disent les les policiers je peux
dire c'est un joli c'est un seul
policier qui dix ans c'est pas les 3
donc je conteste
j'ai seulement insulté le voisinage j'ai
insulté le voisinage parce que c'est le
voisinage qui est soi disant qu'à
appeler le commissariat
ensuite il ya le problème de votre
casier judiciaire et il ya une peine de
9 mois ferme qui a été prononcée à votre
encontre le 15 mars 2019
cette peine mouche obligé je vais la
mettre à exécution elles se sont élevées
la décimale non pas ça c'est trop abuser
c'est facile de venir interpellé des
gens qui leur à près de 16 à leurs
maîtres
je veux dire la vérité regardez moi bien
dans les yeux parce que c'est pas des
foudres de guerre
comment voyez gauche droite c'était fini
l'histoire messieurs c'est vrai que vous
avez pas voulu faire du mal mais j'avais
juste pas voulu vous laisse interpeller
non c'est pas présent vous avez assisté
à une première des procédures qui
concernait les violences conjugales
l'eau tiède c'est l'alcool les
stupéfiants sur la route
et puis le dernier terre souvent ici
c'est le stupéfiant et puis douze
infractions c'est différent ici oui
d'abord c'est un parquet on en ressort
plus rurales donc on a déjà pas mal du
tout le même profil de délinquance on a
des infractions différentes par exemple
avec un parka comme montbéliard ou
besançon cdd contentieux plus urbain va
dire ici on va avoir beaucoup de
contentieux liés à l'alcool c'est pas
c'est pas un fantasme et les réponses
pénales bas effectivement elles sont et
seront ici peut-être différente
d'ailleurs parce que là on est plus
sensibilisé à ce type d'infraction pour
pouvoir avoir des réponses peut-être un
peu plus forte que dans d'autres
juridictions
de retour à l'audience
une procédure de comparution immédiate
acceptez-vous d'être jugé aujourd'hui
sur ces faits ou demander un délai et
dans le cadre de la procédure de
comparution immédiate
cela sollicite une formation de trois
juges trois juges professionnels qui en
urgence constitue effectivement un
tribunal pour juger dans un contexte
d'urgence dans un contexte de procédure
immédiate
moi tout ce qu'il dit là je contestais
aucune parole des sorties de choix dans
la juge d'accord donc la bien nommée
ça s'adresse à qui monsieur à la
policière ou à votre compagne quand vous
dites une petite il put
que vous adressez à un moment de manger
qui est ce que vous vendez reçue
positivement viable à personne parce que
c'est pas sorti de ma bouche madame et
puis les insultes qui disent que je les
ai putrajaya j'ai insulté le voisin du
tube d'accord mes voisins du dessus
voilà ce que j'ai insulté madame en plus
peut-être que j'ai dit des insultes à
aucun moment je vais tuer la mère de mon
enfant moi je fais des insultes mais des
menaces de marne sur le coup de collier
à les allumer dire des menaces de mort
c'est impossible
vraiment pas avec quelle commande comme
comment je vais lui dire j'ai donné à
ben jawad il de méthode à charge contre
un type pas déjà seize ou dix sept
condamnations c'est trop facile madame
avec un casier judiciaire déjà bien
chargé le jeune père de famille continue
denis 1 ce qui lui est reproché
le tribunal questionne intérieur
alors quelle sera sa décision réponse
demain